[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
and we have some brand new looks at the
figures for the upcoming spider-man film
no way home people said no way is this
trailer ever gonna release
but the fact that the figures are
dropping now does tease that it's right
around the corner
now throughout this video we're gonna be
going through each one of them and
giving our reaction to it
as well as how we think it plays into
the movie i haven't got a script for
this video and i'm just gonna be
freestyling it like like
spiderman spiderman got to swing through
the city because of driving bands
pull out the web calling flying man out
of the fire into the frying pan
still still got it silk still got the
skills now
the first one is the integrated
spider-man suit which
looks a lot like the iron spider one
however there have been some upgrades to
it and it also looks like it possesses
some of the doctor strange portals that
we can see on the chest and also his
wrist
either spider-man's been taking lessons
from the sorcerer's supreme
or these are sort of upgrades to his
costume since the death of tony stark
the blue on it does look a lot like the
holographic technology that was used to
design a suit and fall from home
so basically that's kind of what i'm
going with now this suit was shown on
lego figures yesterday and we got a
great look at it
and personally i think it looks really
really good i know a lot of people have
problems with it but
yeah it just kind of looks like they've
kind of built on the iron spider design
and made it more in line with the civil
war one from the comics
so i really like it but dumb stumps if
you don't
now under the next one and we see doctor
strange with a shovel
obviously if you've seen the first look
at the film you'll know that the sanctum
sanctorum is completely covered in dust
so i'm guessing that after the snap it
was completely run down
and now he's doing the cleanup job just
sweeping it off but
the guy has magical powers what are you
doing wasting your time sweeping
you look like the bloody guy from the
end of home alone now next is the
wingsuit
which really builds upon the one that
was in homecoming and it gives him the
ability to glide by the looks of it
this is a slight upgrade to the black
one from far from home and i'm guessing
that they've just added this web stuff
in
to make it to make it more fun looking
now it is
called upgraded suit so yeah that makes
a lot of sense and i probably should
have read that before doing this video
next is mj and she looks a lot more
scholarly her hair's tied back and she's
got a lovely designer coat on
as well as a v-neck jumper we also have
ned in a football jersey
i think they think they're called
football jerseys i'm not american so so
don't dislike the video
the thumbs-up's right there and he's
also got a nice 90s middle parting
now the next suit looks really really
good and this is the black and gold one
this was shown in a lot of concept art
and it looks very similar to the one
that peter got at the end of the
spider-man ps4 game
absolutely love this design and from
what i've heard this is what the
character gets
at the end of the movie now we have some
more realistic looking toys there's the
iron spider one
and also the black and gold one where we
can see the red more around his
fingertips
on top of this we also have jay jonah
jameson
doing his lovely point in the air and
you
you can look at this and know exactly
what this guy's thinking
he is thinking that spider-man is a
menace
where is that trailer as well we've got
a great close-up of him and i absolutely
love this figure
if if this is a rare figure and it's up
for 150
on ebay i'm i'm i'm remortgaging the
house together i don't care
up next is doctor strange holding the
eye of agamotto which
is a bit strange as we do know that the
time stone was taken from it
clearly that's either been brought back
or something else is inside it
and it's very intriguing that he's
clasping this quite tight we also have a
nine spider nerf toy gun i think
i don't think this is going to be in the
movie but yeah they kind of always do
these tie-in sorts of things
and hey if the kids want to pretend that
spider-man goes around shooting people
with nerf guns
and that's completely fine we also can
see that the iron spider legs are back
and there is a figure where he's on a
motorbike however draw your eyes to the
web slinger
and you can see that he has a glider
with this which clearly makes a tie in
with the previous figure
now from some of the standalone figures
it does look like peter is going to be
getting a lot of upgrades to his webs
there's one that has mystery web gear on
it and this
really shoots out in a sort of it almost
looks like the ruins that doctor strange
has but we do know that it's web related
it seems like this comes in many shapes
and sizes and from what i've heard
sandman is in the movie
i can see peter having to use website
this in order to capture him and it just
makes a lot of sense that he'd have to
upgrade his designs as he is going
toe-to-toe with the sinister six
several of these include clamps and
different designs that we just haven't
seen before
so it looks like the creative team could
be really pushing the boat out here in
terms of what peter can do with his web
slingers
now bear in mind toys should never be
taken at face value
and a lot of the times companies just
sort of get a basic design and take free
reign with it
this could mean that these features
aren't in the movie at all but judging
by the suits and how they constantly
appear
i would say that they definitely are now
interestingly these figures all come as
part of a set
and you can see that mysterio iron man
and the vulture are among these
however if you look very closely on the
packaging you will see that these
figures are pulling from spider-man
homecoming as well as far from home
typically when you know toy companies to
think oh we missed the boat with the
last couple of movies
so we'll just bundle it in with this no
way home stuff and sell the figures that
we couldn't sell last time
that might be a bit cynical of me to say
but don't get your hopes up that
mysterio and the vulture are going to be
in this film
now this kind of carries across to the
lego sets which i know got a lot of
publicity yesterday however if you look
very closely at the mysterio one
you will see it says inspired by marvel
studios spider-man far from home
this means that lego are basically just
capitalizing on all the properties
within the franchise
and pushing out as many different toy
sets as they can doing stuff like this
also avoids spoilers as people can just
say well it's not a no way home
it's actually just pulling from far from
home however saying that we do have a
sanctum sanctorum set and we know for
definite that this location will be in
the film
now this set also has a hidden passage
and from what i know behind the scenes
stuff peter will be going down into the
basement to make some big discoveries
don't spoil what they are as it could
potentially ruin the movie for you
but if you want to know we have done a
full plot leak breakdown
now interestingly there's also a game
controller on one of the sofas
so it looks like the rumors about peter
being homeless are indeed true
peter is of course on the run so it
makes sense that he would lay low at the
sanctum sanctorum as
this is of course a sanctuary now that's
all of the toys and the new looks and i
have to say
yeah i don't care what the rest of the
internet is saying i think the suits
look absolutely gorgeous
people are just saying they look a bit
crappy and what we've seen before but it
makes sense that peter would pull from
his best suit and try and upgrade that
also i love the titans with the runes as
it shows that dr strange is sort of
becoming a mentor to the character
in the wake of the death of tony stark
this just makes a lot of sense
and though i don't want pieterlin magic
perhaps strange is just shooting his
abilities onto the characters so that he
can help him fight
this is of course happening on the
upgraded suit and it does make sense
that they pull from science and magic to
help peter survive
magic is just science that hasn't been
classed as science yet
or something along those lines so maybe
they're just meshing the two
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the suits and the toys so
make sure you comment below and let me
know
if you enjoyed this video then please
smash the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this each and every day
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of july
in which you pick three random comments
to win an mcu box set of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
now if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of loki episode 4 which will
be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace
you